how's it going everybody so day 2 of
trailer watch last night just like the
report said we got the official full
Captain Marvel trailer and it was
awesome
if you weren't aware the first trailer
that came out for Captain Marvel was
actually a teaser trailer so this is the
first full trailer if you haven't seen
it yet go to Marvel's YouTube page check
it out come back here for the full
trailer breakdown like I said it's
pretty incredible and I'll put the link
up above now as far as the Avengers 4
trailer coming out tomorrow tomorrow
December 5th has been declared
officially by the US government a
National Day of Mourning due to the
passing of President Bush and his
funeral so sadly Disney has decided not
to release the trailer tomorrow what my
property you can't have it but I did you
a big favor I know it's really really
sad news and I know it's probably hard
to understand especially for some people
who may not live inside of the US so
I'll try to explain a few things to try
and help you understand where exactly
Disney is coming from so one is out of
respect Disney's headquarters is in the
US and again the US government has
declared tomorrow December 5th a
National Day of Mourning
and they're not the only company to do
this just a few months ago Nintendo
decided to delay that direct because of
a huge earthquake in Japan so local
events for companies do affect things
worldwide another thing is this is going
to be a trailer for a movie about a
bunch of people that just died so since
there's a funeral going on right now you
can see how they would want to delay
this and another thing is and people may
not like this but Disney is a company
they care about profit and since
tomorrow is a national mourning day in
the US the New York Stock Exchange will
be closed Disney will not release The
Avengers for trailer while the New York
Stock Exchange is closed they just won't
their stock prices can't be positively
affected that day so they won't do it
the reality is Disney has their reasons
but we're still really really close to
getting the trailer it's still looking
like it's going to be this week again
this week is supposed to be huge for
Marvel the Captain Marvel trailer was
supposed to come out Monday it did the
Avengers 4 trailer was supposed to come
out tomorrow on Wednesday that's getting
pushed back due to the National Day of
Mourning
but then on Thursday December 6th we
have the game Awards and the Russo
brothers are going to appear there and
we're supposed to get a full reveal of
the Avenger
project game and then of course there
are rumors that the Spider Man fight
from home trailer is supposed to be
released this week as well so a lot is
happening for Marvel and not to mention
all of the holiday movies are coming out
Marvel is going to want The Avengers 4
trailer to premiere during these movies
again it was supposed to come out
Wednesday it was scheduled this is only
a slight delay could be just a day I'll
update you as soon as I know more he
asks us to trust him as we cower behind
it I wish I were comforted Anthony I
really do but some good news is that the
Avengers for prelude should still come
out tomorrow so we'll probably know a
little bit more about what Avengers 4 is
really about tomorrow so keep your heads
up the trailer is not far away most
likely still happening this week I'll
let you know it hurt me to make this
video but of course I promise to keep
you all updated on everything that
happens and if I hear anything about
them setting a new date for the trailer
I will let you all know asap just hang
in there a little bit longer as always
thank you all so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]